Hello friends, we want to welcome you to
our program I like to know. A program
that many if not all of you love. Uh
it's one of our the programs that the
audience really enjoy because they have
the opportunity to send their questions
and and hear an hear an answer here and
interact with us. So welcome again to
this program. I like to know and um I
have here Pastor Boore and today it's
just the two of us that will be
answering some of the questions that
came in. Uh it's good to be with you
Pastor Boore. It's always good to be
with you and thank you for uh being um
willing soldier so to speak to come and
join us. I know that you're a very busy
person because you're pastoring a couple
of churches and uh we really appreciate
you coming in and helping with this
program.
>> Amen. My pleasure. And before we uh
pray, we want to remind you that if you
want to send your questions, you can do
so to the following address. TV
tbsv.org.
Again, that's tbsumptv.org.
Uh send the questions and they will be
answered in the order they are received.
Some of them might be answered directly,
but uh most likely your question will
appear on the program. Uh Pastor Bo, why
don't you lead us in prayer as we begin?
Let's pray. Father in heaven, we come
before your awesome throne and we come
boldly because we come in the name of
Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> But at the same time, we come humbly
because we realize that our knowledge is
so limited.
>> Yes.
>> So we ask for the presence of your holy
spirit with us that uh we might have
thoughts that are in harmony with your
will. Amen. [clears throat] That you
will give us words to speak.
>> We also ask that you will bless those
who are watching this program that it
might be a blessing in their spiritual
walk with the Lord. This we pray in the
precious and holy name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Okay. So we have uh first question here
that we're going to discuss today comes
from Huffman.
And this is the question is about the
Holy Spirit. Why is the Holy Spirit
sometimes referred to as he and other
times as it in scripture? For example,
in Romans 8:26 and 27 and also in John
chapters 14:15 and 16. Thank you. This
is a very good question. Uh perhaps it
would be good if we could read uh first
the verses that he's quoting in Romans
chap 8 26 and 27
>> and then we can make some comments on
that if you don't mind pastor Boore.
>> Sure. Uh Romans 8 26 and 27 uh in the
New King James Version reads in the
following way. Likewise, the Spirit also
helps in our weaknesses.
For we do not know what we should pray
for as we ought, but the Spirit himself
makes intercession for us with groanings
which cannot be uttered. Verse 27, now
he who searches the hearts knows what
the mind of the Spirit is, because he
makes intercession for the saints
according to the will of God.
Okay. So, so here we have verse 28,
uh, excuse me, verse 27. It says, "He
who searches the heart knows what the
mind of the spirit is because he makes
intercession for the things according to
the will of God." So that he here is a
reference to the Holy Spirit. Now, it is
true that sometimes is used as it and
and part of this will have to do with
language, but anything you you have to
say about this, pastor. I think that the
reason why uh the uh the word it is used
>> is because in the Greek language
>> the word spirit is neuter.
>> Yes.
>> You see in Greek you have masculine,
feminine and neuter.
>> Yes. And because it's a neuter uh word
uh then the uh definite article to which
is the the neuter in Greek is used with
the spirit.
>> Yes.
>> In other places because the spirit is a
person according to the spirit of
prophecy uh he is referred to both by
Ellen White and by scripture as he
>> correct and you're correct. I was
looking at the Greek here in verse 26
for example. It says to
>> right
>> which is you know as you said nma uh is
is spirit it can be referred to the holy
spirit or the spirit of a person it's
the same word
>> and is a neuter
>> so because it's a neuter then the
article you know is the article here toe
in this case because it's neuter and um
and that can be translated sometimes as
you know it in in this case or in other
cases because the translators know that
is referring to the Holy Spirit, they
can replace it by he. Um but uh but this
has to do more with the semantics or the
grammar of the Greek language, but not
necessarily to a contradiction in
scripture that the Holy Spirit is God
and the Holy Spirit is a person.
>> I think it'd be a good idea, you know,
we've dealt with this before in the
context of the Godhead, the three
persons of the Godhead. Uh but you know
when it comes to the Holy Spirit we need
to be very careful that we don't
speculate.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Ellen White wrote in the book Acts of
the Apostles page 52, the nature of the
Holy Spirit is a mystery.
>> Men cannot explain it because the Lord
has not revealed it to them. Men having
fanciful views may bring together
passages of scripture and put a human
construction on them. But the acceptance
of these views will not strengthen the
church regarding such mysteries which
are too deep for human understanding.
Silence is golden.
>> So you know I don't go into speculating
how the Holy Spirit works, what the Holy
Spirit is.
>> Yeah.
>> I believe that the spirit the Holy
Spirit is the third person of the
Godhead.
>> Amen.
>> Uh and I might read here a quotation
from the spirit of prophecy on this
point. Uh because some people are saying
that there's only two people in the
godhead, the father and the son and not
the holy spirit. Um Ellen White in Bible
training school March 1 1906.
Uh and we know that she wrote this
because some people say well this
quotation is in evangelism and fume put
together the book evangelism and so on.
But this is from Ellen White directly
>> right
>> writesh she wrote there are three living
persons of the heavenly trio in the name
of these three I think that she believed
that there were three
>> said there are three living persons of
the heavenly trio in the name of these
three and then she puts the father the
son and the holy ghost those who receive
Christ by living faith are baptized and
these powers will cooperate with the
obedient subjects of heaven in their
efforts to live the new life in Christ.
>> Amen.
>> So, Ellen White is explicit, you know,
she says, uh, three persons,
>> yeah,
>> heavenly trio in the name of these three
and then she mentions them. So, there's
no escaping that there are three persons
in the godhead.
>> Exactly. So, I think as you quoted,
first of all, there is the warning of
being careful with the nature of the
Holy Spirit. But but these other quotes
make it clear without going beyond that
there are three persons in the godhead
and and we should just leave it there
>> and not speculate beyond that.
>> Yeah. And uh you know it's it's
interesting the reason why people think
that the Holy Spirit is kind of like a
maybe force
>> a a a force or or some invisible power
or something is many times because of
the metaphors that are used to describe
him. He's described as oil, rain, uh
fire, uh dove. Well, the Holy Spirit is
not those things,
>> right?
>> Those are metaphors that describe
functions of the Holy Spirit.
>> And so, we need to be careful that we
don't think that the Holy Spirit is a
substance that is poured into us like
water. Um we we do speak of the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit in the
latter reign but once again latter rain
is a metaphor.
>> Yes,
>> it's not literal.
>> And before we move to the next question,
I want to comment something else.
When the Bible talks about a person
or you know and and and Ellen White of
course um is not necessarily saying
someone that looks exactly like a human
being,
>> right? You know the definition of a
person in scripture in my understanding
is an independent center of
consciousness
uh that has a body of course it's not
just a force and all of that we cannot
speculate in regards to how exactly God
looks like
>> but is is is an independent center of
consciousness it has his own will that's
what I'm saying judgment reasoning
uh eternal will so
I mention this because some people say
yes well the Holy Spirit is the spirit
spirit of Christ as if Christ in heaven
it's the humanity but the Holy Spirit
here on earth is his divinity but it's
the same Christ well that in in biblical
terms is not possible because then
you know when we talk about human nature
that we're in the image of of God we
also have a spirit but is part of us
>> so it's not an independent entity from
the body from me
>> so we should not argue from that
standpoint in regards to Jesus Christ
because he became human that now he has
two separate entities that are the same
person. The Holy Spirit his divinity and
and Jesus Christ his humanity. I think
in Jesus Christ divinity and humanity
were mingled together. The Holy Spirit
is independent of that.
>> Right. Very very good explanation. uh
you know if if the what what I tell
people who say that well the Holy Spirit
is the uh the divine spirit aspect of
Christ
>> you know because he's human and he's
divine
>> but but that would mean that that the
spirit is still part of his personh
>> right
>> right yes
>> because because you can't separate you
know his his divinity from his humanity
because they were mingled according to
the spirit of prophecy.
>> That's correct. Very good. Well, thank
you so much. I think uh this answers the
question and please let us know if you
have more questions regarding this. I
know that this is a very very complex
subject. The BRRI recently published two
volumes on on the Trinity. Very good.
Very good. You can actually download
them for free in uh Kindle if you want
to have them in electronic form. And
they did an excellent job explaining all
of these. Now we go to the next
question. This one comes from Samson the
Middle Beach. He's writing from Myrtle
Beach, South Carolina. And it says, "In
heaven, there is no sin or sadness.
How will we remember those of our loved
ones that did not make it?"
>> Well, the first thing that I would say
is that um the premise that in heaven
there is no sin. I would agree that
there's no sin now, but sin did
originate in heaven.
>> Correct.
>> Uh in a in a perfect place, a beautiful
place, a place that did had no evil.
>> Mhm.
>> Um and uh and heaven does have sadness.
Uh the spirit of prophecy tells us that
when the angels saw the way that Christ
was treated uh in Pilot's court and his
passion, they were they they quit
playing their harps. They quit singing
because they were sad.
>> Yeah. Uh sadness is not sin.
>> Yes.
>> Sorrow is not sin.
>> God has sorrow when he sees that people
reject the message.
>> Yeah.
>> And so uh and so in heaven there is no
sin. Now we know that now there is no
sin because the the devil has been cast
out.
>> Uh or sadness. But but of course the
question has to do with how will we
remember those of our loved ones that
did not make it there? In other words,
when we get there, uh how can we be
happy if some of our relatives and
friends are not there?
>> Yeah. Well, I think um and and I don't
know if you agree with me, Pastor Boore,
but I want to read from Revelation 21
>> verse
uh
I think we're gonna read verse four.
Revelation 21 verse4.
Now before I read this text, the context
is
from chapter 20 where we see that the
final destruction of the wicked. You see
they're before the throne of God, the
white throne and the books are open.
They're judged and then fire comes down
from heaven and they're destroyed.
And then in that context, John sees the
new Jerusalem. And then it says in verse
four, "And God will wipe away every tear
from their eyes, and there shall be no
more death, nor sorrow, nor crying, and
there shall be no more pain, for the
former things have passed away." Now
though often times we we refer or we use
this text to say you know heaven is
going to be um you know no more
sickness, no more pain and all of that
which is yes the verse is talking about
that but specifically it says here God
will wipe away every tear from their
eyes. I believe I believe that in the
immediate context this is talking about
the tears that the saints inside the
city shed for those outside the city.
>> God doesn't want a torture that God
doesn't want this memory of the lost
ones because it's going to be very
painful. It's painful for God. It's
going to be painful for the saints. It's
not that the saints are going to rejoice
in the death of the wicked. I mean I
think we will be sensitive to that but
God doesn't want our remembrance to be
tortured throughout eternity with the
thought that you know my mom is not here
my friend didn't make it after that it
says God will wipe away perhaps that
would be a reference to he will erase
from our minds those memories um why why
do I say that the the righteous will say
it will see it there's actually a text
here in the book of Psalms I think it's
Psalm 37 7.
Um,
Psalm 37
and um,
if you want to comment, I think I lost
the verse, but uh, we'll get there.
Yeah, I was thinking of Isaiah chapter
65 and verse 17
uh where it says uh for behold I create
new heavens
>> and a new earth and the former shall not
be remembered or come to mind.
>> Amen.
>> So I think that text is is pretty
explicit. If I might say something about
uh Revelation chapter 21, the the verses
the verses that you read, verse three
and verse four.
>> Um
Revelation 21 verse1 really should be
the conclusion of chapter 20.
>> 20. Yes.
>> Uh because a after death and Hades are
cast into the lake of fire. Verse 14. Uh
whoever is not found written in the book
of life was cast into the lake of fire
after the destruction of the wicked.
Then in verse twe one it says now I saw
a new heaven and new earth for the first
heaven of the first earth had passed
away and there was no more sea. That's
the climax. In other words, yes, new
heavens and new earth after the
destruction of the wicked. Verse two
begins a new cycle.
>> Verse two uh reaches its climax in verse
eight
>> once again with the destruction of the
wicked. And and that's important because
because it says, "Then I, John, saw
verse two, the holy city, New Jerusalem,
coming down out of heaven from God,
prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband." We know that this is after the
millennium before the destruction of the
wicked.
>> Yes.
>> That the new Jerusalem descends. So this
begins a new cycle
>> from the time that Jesus descends after
the millennium, the Mount of Olive
splits open. the holy city uh rests in
that spot. And then a voice is heard.
The wicked have not been destroyed yet.
>> Yeah.
>> It says, "And I heard a loud voice from
heaven saying, behold, the tabernacle of
God is with men. He will dwell with them
and they shall be his people. God
himself will be with them and be their
God." Notice all the verses are future
>> from this point.
>> Then verse four, and God will wipe every
away every tear from the eyes. There
shall be no more death at this point.
There still is because the wicked has
not been destroyed.
>> Yes.
>> So it says nor sorrow nor crying. There
shall be no more pain for the former
things have passed away. Then he who sat
on the throne said behold I make all
things new. It's really future tense. I
will make things new. And he said to me,
write for these words are true and
faithful. And he said to me, it is done.
I am Alpha and Omega, the beginning and
the end. I will give of the fountain of
water of life freely to him who thirsts.
He who overcomes. These are those who
are in the city shall inherit all things
and I will be his God and he shall be my
son. But then it reaches the same
climax. But the cowardly, the
unbelieving, the abominable, murderers,
sexually immoral, sorcerers, idolattors,
and all liars shall have shall have
their part in the lake which burns with
fire and brimstone which is the second
death. So So this promise in verse four
that we quote, God will wipe away every
tear from the eyes. You know there will
be tears when the wicked are being
destroyed.
>> Exactly. Yeah. And the verse that you
read from Isaiah is excellent because
the former things will pass away. They
will not there will not be memory of
them. I found the verse uh Psalm 37:34.
It says, "Wait on the Lord and keep his
way. He shall exalt you to inherit the
land." And then it says when the wicked
are cut off, you shall see it.
>> Here the Bible says it very clear that
we are going to see it.
>> Right?
>> And uh you know unfortunately there will
be families that will be split.
>> You know some wills be saved, some will
be lost. I imagine that's going to be
very painful. But as as you explained in
the context of Revelation 20 and 21, uh
God will wipe away every tear from their
eyes. And Isaiah, we just read that that
former things will pass away. That
remembrance will not be in our minds
now. It will be in the heart of God. You
know, sin brought an eternal pain in the
heart of God. Uh that that that void
that someone could have been there,
didn't make it, and yet that will be
something that God himself will will
bear for eternity. Now if I can uh just
read here an interesting statement here
uh from Ellen White. Uh you know she
received visions where she was
transported to the future to the distant
future. And in one of those visions
she was transported to the time when
she's in the kingdom with two of the
pioneers [laughter]
of uh of the 1844 movement. And I want
to read that statement. Um it comes from
early writings page 17. [clears throat]
She says we all went under the tree that
is the tree of life and sat down to look
at the glory of the place. Remember
she's being transported to the future
and this is actually going to take place
in the future. Uh and then she says,
"When brethren Fitch and Stockman who
had preached the gospel of the kingdom
and whom God had laid in the grave to
save them, came up to us and asked us
what we had passed through while they
were sleeping.
>> They passed through very difficult
times, right?" [clears throat]
>> And then she writes, "We tried to call
up our greatest trials."
>> Love that. But they looked so small
compared with a far more exceeding and
eternal weight of glory that surrounded
us that we could not speak them out.
>> And we all cried out, "Hallelujah!
Heaven is cheap enough." And we touched
our glorious harps and made heaven's
arches ring.
>> Amen. There it is.
>> It's going to be so glorious that the
things of the past are really not going
to come to mind.
>> Yes. Amen. and and and we have you know
that assurance of that beautiful promise
that heaven indeed is going to be a
happy place. We should not doubt about
it. Heaven is going to be a happy place.
And what is going to make it even
happier is because we'll be in the
presence of Jesus Christ. So I hope that
you and I can be there with Jesus.
Pastor Bo, we have perhaps uh I think
this question is not very complicated.
We can answer in the few minutes we have
is um question from Samson again. Um
filio is this how they supplant Jesus
Christ with the pope? Um
>> yeah I don't I don't exactly see
uh how that he reaches that conclusion
>> right
>> uh Filio
um you know before um before the council
of Nika in the year 3:25 AD uh it said
that the Holy Spirit comes from the
father
>> but in na they added and the son and his
son
>> and this caused the rift between the
eastern church and the western church
>> uh you know because the western the
eastern church wanted to just say that
the spirit proceeded from the father
>> na added in from the son
>> the son
>> and uh the the eastern church felt that
this actually messed up the the the idea
of of the godhead
>> um so I don't see how that is connected
directly with the idea that uh this is
how they supplant uh Jesus Jesus Christ
with the pope. I don't I don't know if
you
>> No, I was just going to say the
conclusion.
>> No, I just was going to say the same
thing. Um, you know, thank you for that
the background to the word filio is son.
Filio from the sun. Okay. So, so that's
what it means that phrase and I don't
see how this was used to supplant Jesus
Christ with the pope. I really don't
know how our dear brother came to that
conclusion. But this is basically what
filioke is. Uh for those of you who
might be interested in in this term very
theological uh if you don't know the
history of the nine creed and the
trinitarian debates during this time uh
this is a this is a a big portion of of
that. But anyways, anything else you
want to add in the last minute we have
regarding this question?
>> Well, we have only just a few seconds
left. Uh I want to thank all of you for
uh being willing to watch our program
and for sending your questions to us. Um
I want to encourage you to keep us in
your prayers. Uh we have a lot of
programming that we do here at Secrets
Unsealed and some TV. Uh we constantly
need your prayers. Uh because uh God
needs to guide continue to guide this
ministry. We also appreciate your
financial support of Secrets Unsealed
and Some TV. Um people don't realize how
many funds are necessary for this
ministry to continue functioning. We
need all of the personnel that we have
here. And uh so we want to thank you so
much for those who are supporting our
ministry financially. Uh we appreciate
it very much and we trust that the
programming that we do as a result of
your prayers and your financial support
are a blessing to your own spiritual
walk with the Lord. Thank you so much
for joining us. God bless you and we'll
see you next time on I'd Like to Know